a deadly night of shelling in kiev
that many in ukraine's capital fear may
become all too common right now everyone
is angry i talk to the people they don't
want to leave they really upset what
what russian soldiers do it with city
homes are destroyed buildings in ruins
and a blanket curfew is now in effect
until at least thursday
in anticipation of further attacks we'd
like to
ask you to help yourself by helping us
president vladimir zelinsky continued
his appeal to european leaders for more
arms
destruction in the second city of harkev
too normally home to one and a half
million people
this resident who describes himself as
russian says he doesn't need weapons
you want to fight putin come find me
black belt i could tear you apart with
my bare hands he says
in besieged mario paul more civilians
escaped in some 2000 cars tuesday but
ukraine says russia is again blocking
aid from entering
essentially being suffocated
in this city right now with no aid the
eu says at least 2400 civilians have
been killed here so far we know of
families who are undoing oil heaters to
take the water coolant out as a last
resort as something to drink the
regional governor says 400 patients and
staff are effectively being held hostage
by russian troops in this now damaged
hospital
further to the west russia claims it now
controls all of kersen region
anger and sadness are only mounting
ukrainians mourning some of the 1300
soldiers the government says have been
killed so far that number will surely
rise as the latest round of peace talks
have again failed to produce any obvious
progress
redmond shannon global news london